[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا رامي القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زوايا هو من جميع
[موسيقى]
الاحتجاجات الاشهر الثلاثاء حلوا شرطه
الاخلاق
ومراجعه قانون الحجاب
اسطول ناقلات الظل يتهياوا لانقاذ نفطي
روسيا المعاقبه وموسكوت حذر الغرب من يحدد
سقفا لنقتنا سيحرم منه
العراق مريض يحول الفساد والغلاء بينه
وبين علاجه وما في دواء تكبده 15 مليار
دولار سنويا
تابعونا معنا الليله ايضا
اقتصاد العالم يكافح لعبوره
لكنه هو اخرى تنتظره 100 مليار دولار من
الديون المتاثره
[موسيقى]
بعد اشهر ثلاث من الاحتجاجات في ايران لجا
النظام الى تقديم تنازل او على الاقل كبش
فداء في محاوله الامتصاص غضب الشارع ومن
افضل من شرطه الاخلاق التي بدات الازمه
للتضحيه بها بعد ان اتهمت بالتسبب في وفاه
الشابه مهساين امين
الشرطه راى فيه العالمون بالنظام ومنهم
الناشطه مسيح علي
المطارده من الامن الايراني انه مجرد
تكتيك لوقف الانتفاضه في الشارع وقالت في
تغريده لها على تويتر مع نشر مقاطع مصوره
للتعدي على النساء في الشوارع قالت ان
الايرانيين لم يواجهوا البنادق
شرطه الاخلاق وانما لاسقاط النظام
[موسيقى]
اذا احتجاجات ايران تقضي على الجهه التي
اشعلت شراره الاحتجاجات بعد اتهامها
بالتسبب في وفاه الشابه مساء امين نتحدث
هنا عن شرطه الاخلاق التي اعلن امس المدعي
العام حلها بعد اكثر من شهرين ونصف من بدء
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه بيان لدعاء العام
اضافه ان الغاء شرطه الاداب او ما تعرفوا
بدوريات الاخلاق ياتي من قبل الجهه التي
اسستها في الماضي مع فك ارتباطها بالقضاء
اعلان المدعي العام محمد جعفر منتظري عن
الغاء دوريات الاخلاق اثار جدلا في ايران
حول ما اذا كانت الحكومه جاده في تطبيق
هذا القرار ام انه مجرد تكتيك لتهدئه
الشارع الذي باتى يطالب بتغيير النظام
برمته
تسريحات منتظري في ندوه بتهران ركزت على
انه رغم الغاء هذه الدوريات الا ان الجهات
القضائيه ستستمر بمراقبه سلوك المجتمع
خاصه فيما يتعلق بالحجاب قبل ذلك اعلن
المدعي العام يوم الخميس ان البرلمان وما
يسمى بالمجلس الاعلى
لثوره الثقافيه سيبديان رايهما خلال
اسبوعين في قضيه الحجاب الاجباري في
البلاد
[موسيقى]
كم
ذكرت النظام الايراني لتهدئه الشارع مؤقتا
والهدف السيطره على الاحتجاجات فالمؤسسات
الرئيسيه للرقابه المشدده على النساء ما
زالت قائمه وعلى راسها دوريات البسيج
والشرطه والامن الداخليه وحتى شرطه المرور
في الوقت ذاته يعتبر الكثير من الناشطين
انه مجرد الاعلان عن قرار الالغاء وحتى لو
كان شكليا
اجازا للمتظاهرين سيدفع النظام نحو تقديم
مزيدا من التناسلات كما انه سيشكل دافع عن
اكبر لاستمرار الاحتجاجات بعد الناشطين
اعتبر وان القرار الاخير يهدف ايضا لتخفيف
الضغوط الدوليه عن النظام مع تزايد
العقوبات من الحكومات الغربيه بسبب قتل
المتظاهرين واستمرار القمه
البريطانيه فرضت الاسبوع الماضي عقوبات
على شرطه الاخلاق والرئيس العام لها
لقائدها في طهران عقوبات الاتحاد الاوروبي
طالت ايضا عناصر من دوريات شرطه الاخلاق
والمسؤول عن اعتقال مهسه امينه ومسؤولين
اخريننا ايضا ادرجت الولايات المتحده
وكندا شرطه الاخلاق الايرانيه على قائمه
العقوبات بعد احتجاجات واسعه النطاق على
مستوى البلاد العقوبات وصلت ايضا لشركه
تيندي الصينيه التي وفرت اجهزه التعرف على
الوجه لصالح الحكومه الايرانيه بعدما اعلن
موسى غضنفر ابادي رئيس اللجنه القانونيه
والقضائيه في البرلمان عن استخدام تقنيه
التعرف على الوجوه كبديل لدوريات شرطه
الاخلاق
اصبر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
رغم قرار يحلي شرطه الاخلاق انتشرت في
ايران اليوم دعوات لبدي اضراب عام لمده
ثلاثه ايام اعتبارا من يوم الاثنين في
مسعى لمواصله الضغط
واسفلت دعوات مماثله للاضراب والتعبئه
الجماهيريه في الاسابيع الماضيه عن تصعيد
الاحتجاجات التي عمد البلاد الدعوات طالبت
بتنظيم احتجاجات اليوم الاربعاء المقبل
عندما يزور الرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي جماعه
طهران اللي يلقي كلمه امام طلابها بمناسبه
يوم الطالب الايراني نبقى مع الرئيس
الايراني فبعد ما دعى فيه يوليو الماضي
الى تعبئه جميع مؤسسات الدوله لفرد قانون
الحجاب عاد على وقحه تواصل الاحتجاجات
ليقول ان هناك حلول مرنه في دستور البلاد
الذي صيغ عام
1979 يمكن تطبيقها لتغلب على اي مشكله
في خطاب له بمناسبه يوم الدستور الايراني
اضاف رئيسي ان دستور ايران ليس فيه اي
طريق مسدود وان تنظيمه وصياغته يجب ان
تكون مرنه بما يضمن تنفيذ الدستور واداره
شؤون البلاد
[موسيقى]
ثابته وغير قابله للتغيير جمهوريه النظام
واسلاميته ومبدا الاستقلال والحريه
والحقوق والحريات التي يصرح بها الدستور
اساليب واليات لتطبيق القانون ولكن يمكن
دراستها
وانضم الينا من لندن الباحث السياسي
والاكاديميه مهداد خنساري اهلا بك معنا
ليلى السيد ماهر زاد يعني شرطه الاخلاق حل
هذه الشرطه هو انجاز مهمله شك
للمحتاجين الا انه يبقى تراجعا بالخانه
اييي
اجتماعيه وليس في الخانه السياسيه وليس في
الخانه الاقتصاديه خاصه بانه مطالب
المحتجين تخطط مساله الحجاب وشرطه الاخلاق
هؤلاء يريدون اسقاط هذا النظام بكل رؤوسه
هذه الخطوه من النظام هل ستزيد من همم
يعني همم من ما يريده المحتاجين هل ذلك
سيرضيهم ام سيزيدهم عزما لانه همم يعني
همم
الخطوه الاولى التنازل الاول حصل
هذا لا يشكل تنازلا
بل ما قاله النائب العام في ايران اي ان
شرطه الاخلاق
لن يتم حلها لكن
وهذا عامل مهم هناك كلمه لكن
النظام يتوقعوا من
شرطه الاخلاق التي تمت تشكيلها من قبل
النظام ان تكون نافذه اي بمعنى ان الحجاب
لا بد من ارتدائه بصوره مستمرا صحيح انه
لن يكون هناك شرطه اخلاق البال سوف تكون
هناك جهات اخرى سوف تعمل على الوفاء
بتطلعات الحكومه فيما يتعلق بارتداء
الحجاب
والانصيعي لهذه الاوامر فاذا الصوره لم
تتغير ولا ارى ان هذا يشكل تنازل من قد
يشعر المتظاهرين بالسعاده وكما جاء في
تقريركم بان المطالب قد فاقت حد الحجاب
لذا لا ارى صراحه
ان هذا سوف يرضي او يهدي او يهديء او يخفف
من مشاعر المتظاهرين وخاصه ان الايام
الثلاثه الماضيه كانت قد برزت في اليوم
الثالث الاخير منها على وجه التحديد في
مناسبه يوم الطالب الذي يعود الى 56 سنه
لدى قد نرى تصعيدا كبيرا من الاحداث
سنتحدث عن هذا الطفل من الايام ولكن سيد
مهداه يعني الان حلت شرطه الاخلاق ولكن
النظام بقيه هذا نظام القائم على مبدا
افعل ما اريد ما اريد فعليا هل من يضمن
انه لن يؤسس شرطه الاخلاق او بمسمى اخر
يعني من حل لا يمكن ان يؤسس من جديد
درس دروس
ان النظام لن يفعل ذلك وقد يقدم على هذا
التصرف وقد قلت ان النائب العام كان محددا
في مساله انه لن تكون شرطه الاخلاق موجوده
لكنهم سوف يعملون على تطبيق نفس القواعد
السابقه وهذا ما تم ايضاعه بصوره رجاليه
لن يعد هذا تنازلا او يسمى تنازلا
بل مجرد ازاله هيئه محدده والتي كانت
تستخدم اي ش- اي شرطه الاخلاق التي لم لا
تعد مرتبطه بالهيئه القضائيه في ايران بل
هي عباره عن تنظيم
ينطوي تحت سلطه مكتب المرشد الاعلى بمعنى
انها لم تكن جزءا من اجهزه الدوله ولكن
سوف تكون هناك جهات اخرى ضمن النظام
القضائي والشرطه وضمن
قوات انفاذي القانون التي سوف تقوم بانجاز
نفس هذه المهام هذه ليست عمليه تنازل
والمساله لم تنتهي وما من شخص في ايران
يعتقد باي طريقه مختلفه لماذا ذكرته لك
للتو نعم
هناك
تظاهرات واضراب غدا همم الذي هو بشكل او
باخر رساله على هذا القرار بانه نحن
مستمرون بهذه الاحتجاجات همم بالمقابل ما
تصورك لطريقه تعامل النظام الان مع هذه
التظاهرات لانه يعتبر بانه سبب شراره هذه
الاحتجاجات كان شرطه الاخلاق والحجاب الان
حلينا الشرطه
من المراحل
شرطه الاخلاق كانت هي الهدف الرئيسي لكن
مع تعاظم
حده الامور وزياده عدد الوفيات التي فقد
ال 400 وعدد الاعتقالات التي وصلت الى
1800 شخص فان الامور قد تغيرت
والحقيقه الامر هي
ان هذه اللفته الصغيره بحل شرطه الاخلاق
اي شيء بل سوف تكون هناك بعض الهايات
الاخرى التي
تتوكلوا بامهامها الطلاب بحالهم حال
الاخرين في ايران وخاصه القيادات المسلمه
في كردستان وبالوستان بالاضافه
همم الى
منظر الى بيتي ايه اللهم انتظري كلهم قد
طالبه باستفتاء كلهم يطالبون باستفتاح حول
دستوري الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
وحول النظام الحكومه الاسلاميه بحيث يتم
التخلص منها واحلال لها بديمقراطيه الدوله
الغير مستعده على التطرق الى اي من هذه
المشاكل وهم لا يوجد لديهم المزاج بتقديم
اي تنازلات هذا ما تجلى من خلال الاسابيع
الماضيه مع حد تزايد يحدد المظاهرات
واقدام النظام بصوره ممعنا على قمع
المتطهرين
شكرا جزيلا لك اذا البحث والسياسي
والاكاديمي مرداد خنصاري من لندن
[موسيقى]
تابعونا معنا بعد الفاصل
برلمان والعراق صادق على الحكومه لكن
الخلافات بين من شكلوها لم تنتهي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد كل يغني على ليلى اوروبا
تحدد سعر الخام الروسي ومسكوت تبدو غير
ابها بتلك القرارات اما كاف فتنتقدها
وتعتبرها غيرها دعونا نبدا من موافقتي
الدول 27 الاعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي
ومجموعات السبع واستراليا على حد اقصى
لسعر الخام الروسي يبلغ 60 دولارا للبرميل
الواحد ابريما الاتفاق بعد ان كان معلقا
من قبل بولندا التي اعطت الضوء الاخضر
لهذه الخطه رغم انها كانت تعتبر انه محدود
جدا لكنها لم تجد مفارا سوى القبول في
النهايه روسيا وعلى لسان المتحدث باسم
الكريم دي البيسكوفا شددت على عدم رضوخها
لتحديد سقف لسعر نفطها وحددت بعدم تزويد
الدول التي ستطبق هذا السقف سفير روسيا
لدى المنظمات الدوليه في فيينا ميخائيل
اليانوف قالها ايضا بصريح العباره اعتبارا
من العام الجاري ستعيش اوروبا بدون نفط
الروسي
تصفاره روسيا في الولايات المتحده شركه في
هذا الموقف الرسمي الموحد لموسكو رفضه
اعاده صياغه المبادئ الاساسيه للسوق الحره
مؤكده ان الطلب على نفطها سيستمر رغم
القرار الغربي اما الرئيس الاوكراني فولو
دي ميرسيلين سكي فلم يعجبه اساسا ذلك
الرقم المتفق عليه جمله وتفصيلا فهو على
حد تعبيره لا يعكس جديه تخدم الهدف المرجو
لاضعاف موسكو وحرمانها من وسائل استمرار
تمويلي عمليتها العسكريه على ارضه
ساره سوشي جيم ديسكو
[موسيقى]
راضي على موسكو
يكبح قوتها العسكريه خاصه وان الرقم
المحدد لم يتغير كثيرا فسعره راهنا قبل
الدخول الاتفاق حيز التنفيذ غدا يبلغ 65
دولار اعتبر هوزلنسكي قرارا مريحا تماما
لموازنه ما اسماها دوله ارهابيه ورقه
الاتفاق يدججوا ميزانيه موسكو ب 100 مليار
دولار سنويا ستستخدم للحرب وانظمتها وليست
انتهاء انا اذا زعزعتي ذات الدول التي
اتخذت ذلك القرار غير المجدي
يا شباب
صحيح ان نزلتك وصف القرار الصادر بتحديد
سقف لسعر النفط الروسي بانه ينم عن موقف
ضعيفه لكنه مدير مكتب رئاسته في كياف
يحاول ان يتفائل ويرى فيه بصيص امل بان
تدمير اقتصاد روسيا مستمر فالقليل الدائم
خير من كثير منقطع وبينما كانه اوروبا من
وطاه اسعار الطاقه وتلجا لخطوات يراها
محللون غير مجديه بالقدر الكافي تراوغ
روسيا في البحار وبدات وفقه صحيفه
وكانها كانت تستعد لهذا القرار عبر اسطول
من ناقلات النفط يعرف باسمي اسطول الظل
تحاولي على العقوبات والقرارات الدوليه
ووفقا التقارير الغربيه في روسيا اما
اشترت او استاجرت اكثر من 100 كاسحه جليد
قادره على التنقل في البحار المتجمده حول
موانئ البطيق الروسيه لا سيما وان نفطر
روسيه
الحياه الاقتصاديه للبلاد ومفتاح تمويل
للعمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا اسطول مظلم
او غير موازن تختلف التسميات لكن فحواها
واحده ايصال النفط للمشتريين في ظل تزايد
العقوبات على روسيا لضمان استمرار تدفق
العائدات ناقلات الظل هي ناقلات عتيقه شبه
مهتعه عمرها غالبا يتراوح بين 12 و15 عاما
هو عمر لا تحفده عاده شركات النفط الكبرى
بسبب مخاوف تتعلق بالام السلامه
وباسعار منافسه ارتفعت بنسبه
37% في الاونه الاخيره وبغض النظر عن
سرعتها البطيئه لكنها تعتبر ملاذان
لمتابعه التدفقات فهي تباعه بشكل غريب غير
رسمي تماما كما مهمتها نقل النفط ايضا
بطرق ملتويه بعيدا عن الامطار كيف ذلك
ببساطه هي تقوم بتغيير الاعلام التي
تحملها
وتوقف تشغيل اجهزه الارسال او ترسل اشارات
خادعه انما هذا النوع من الاساطير
المشاهدين قبل عشر سنوات لشحن النفط
الايراني بعد ان شددت واشنطن العقوبات على
طهران عام 2012 وزاد الطلب عليها عندما
اعادت اداره ترامب فرض المزيد من العقوبات
روسيا على مر التاريخ صمدت عده مرات في
وجه الصعوبات وستتمكن هذه المره ايضا من
قام بوضع سقف لسعر النفط الروسي سيعاني
كثيرا لاننا اغنياء بالموارد الطبيعيه
داخل البلاد
انضم الينا من باريس الباحث الاقتصادي
الدكتور دانيال ملحم اهلا بك دكتور دانيال
يعني ما تداعيات هذا القرار الغربي ان كان
على روسيا
الفتره القادمه وعلى المدى البعيد هل
سنشهد ايضا اشتعالا باسعار الطاقه
العالميه واسعار السوق
الكرام
القرار بطبيعته اليوم هو يغلب عليه الطابع
السياسي ورسائل السياسيه اكثر ما هي مفعول
اقتصادي كبير لذلك اليوم عندما نتكلم
بالصيغه الحاليه للقرار عمليا لا يؤثر
بشكل كبير على الميزانيه الروسيه باكثر من
10 ل 20 مليار في السنه وبالتالي عمليا
الفائض في في الميزانيه او في موازنه
الروسيه هو كبير جدا وبالتالي لن يؤثر الى
خلال السنتين او ثلاث سنوات
الطويل نعم سوف يكون هناك تاثير بشكل كبير
لماذا ليس من وضع ثقف لهذا الساعه انما
عمليا الوجود البدائل عن النفوذ الذي تصدر
الى اوروبا وبعض الدول
هي اغلب هذه الدول تحاول الوجود عن بدائل
وسوف يجب بدائل عن طريق اعاده خلط اخرى
صناعه النفط العالميه او تجاره النفط
العالميه بطبيعه الحال كما يحدث حاليا
وبالتالي يجري على روسيا و ااا وجود او
ايجاب مستوردين بحلول ما بين اثنين الى
اثنين ونص مليون برميل يوميا وهذا انا
استطيع
لا استطيع ان اجله سوف تجده خلال عام
2023- 2024 وهذه الخسائر الكبرى وماهونا
نبدا نتكلم خسائر لروسيه بحدود 50 او 60
مليار اضيف الى العامل الثاني ايضا الى
انخفاض الانتاج عندما هناك خسائر بهذا
عفوا ضعفت في الصادرات سوف يؤدي الى فائض
في التخزين وبالتالي سوف يؤدي في مكان مع
عمليا الى خفض الانتاج وخفض الانتاج سوف
يؤدي الى ما ادى فنزويلا وبالتالي هنا
الخسائر الفعليه في الاقتصاد الخساره هي
العمل الطويل اكثر ما هو عمليا عن عمل
القصيده
لديها اسواق بديله لديها الصين ولديها
الهند ولكن ماذا عن اوروبا كيف ستعوض نقص
همم النفط الروسي خاصه وانه اليوم ابيك
بلاس قررت الاستمرار بقرارها خفض انتاج
نفض بيه بمستوى همم
ب 2 مليون برميل يوميا يعني ما البدائل
صناعه الغاز ليس عفوا صناعه النفط ليست
كسعه الغاز اليوم كانت اوروبا تستورد
عمليا من من
روسيه بحدود 2.5 مليون ملايين يوميا خلال
من بدء الحرب عمليه خفضت مليون برميل
يوميا هذا المليون مليون برميل كان يذهب
الى الصين والهلال وكانت ال وكانت اوروبا
تستورد هذا الفائض من دول عمليان الشرق
الاوسط وحسد ولخليج اضافه الى البرازيل
والجويه وعمليا عندما اقول ان تجاره
النفطي تجاره السائله جدا يستطيع تستطيع
التعويض وتستطيع همم اوروبا الدخول
والشراء من الاسواق الفوريه او الشراء
بعقود طويله الاجل هناك ليس لن يكون هناك
ازمه كبيره بالنسبه لاوروبا الازمه
الموجوده هي في موضوع الغاز اكثر هي من
موضوع همم موضوع الطاقه انا اعتقد سوف
يكون هناك ازمه نوعا ما في بعض المشتقات
ال- ال- النفضيه كالديزل سوف يكون هناك
ضغوطات سعريه سوف تتاثر فيها اوروبا على
الماده القصير عن طريق زياده الاسعار
وبالتالي زياده التضخم وهذا هذه ما ادي
عمليات الى نعم زياده التضخم ويؤدي الى
بعض المعوقات بالنسبه للدول زياده
العجوزات فيها
الضغوطات السياسيه على حكوماتها ولكن اود
ان اسالك عن نقطه مهمه جدا ولكن باختصار
لو سمحت كيف ستستثمر روسيا هذا القرار
الغربي ضدها باجتماع اوبك بلس القادم
ابريل فبراير فبراير تحديدا خاصه بانه
يمكنها ان تلجا لزرع القلق لدى منتجات
طاقه بانه لا احد فوق راسه يعني مظله
ويمكن لتحديد سقف اسعار النفط ان يطال
الجميع
انا برايي هنا خطوره هذا الوضع سيدتي
عندما نتكلم بها بعض هذه القرارات هذا
القرار غير موجه لروسيه لوحدها او او موجه
الى مكان او زمان ما اغلب ما يحدث بهذه
القرارات هي تكون عمليا رساله سياسيه بل
مطلق ويمكن استخدامها في مكان الماء في
فبراير في اجتماع فبراير لا اعتقد ان تلجا
دول اوبيك الى استفزاز مجموعه الدول السبع
او اغلب الدول الكبرى لماذا لانه عمليا هي
لا تريد ال ال ال ال ال ال الدخول في حرب
بما يسمى اليوم لنادي المشترين او بدا
تكوين ما يسمى بنادي المشترين اليوم
وبالتالي هي لا تريد استفسار على مدى
القصير هي تنتظر بعض الخطوات عمليه ماذا
سيحدث وبناء عليه يمكن ان تقرر انهما ولكن
انا برايي له قبل شهر حزيران او اجتماع
حزيران لن يكون هناك انخفاض واي انخفاض
خلال هذه الفتره سوف يؤدي الى فهم هذه
الرساله انه عمليا دخول فعلا دول اوبك في
حرب مع مجموعه الدول السابع واخدها عمليا
طرف روسيه في هذا المجال لذلك عمليا سوف
تحاض على هذا الستكو اللي خلال السته اشهر
المقبله لك الباحث الاقتصاديه الدكتور
دانيال الملحم
[موسيقى]
انتظار ورئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد الشاعر
السوداني لاكتمالي اعضاء حكومته وصل الى
نهايته اخيرا بالحصول على ثقه البرلمان
منذ 27 من اكتوبر الماضينا لواحد 21 وزيرا
من اعضاء الحكومه الثقه ويوم امس منح
البرلمان ثقته لاخر وزيرين وزير البيئه
والاعمار وبالاغلبيه المطلقه التصويت على
الوزارتين تاجل بسبب خلاف بين الحزبين
الكرديين الرئيسيين الديمقراطي والاتحاد
الوطني الى ان اتى الاعلان الجديد
ليتقاسما الحزبان الوزارتين
وتحضها ثاني حقيبتان باهميه بالغه في
سياقه تصدي الحكومه العراقيه لما تواجهه
البلاد من تحديات وازمات منها الجفاف
والتصحر وانتشار العشوائيات وتهلك البناء
التحتيه في المدن
وكان السوداني شددا خلال عرض برنامج عمل
حكومته على تمسكه بالسعي لتحسين وتطوير
الخدمات التي تمص حياه المواطنين في وقت
تواجهه ملفات شائكه منها الفساد واصلاح
الاقتصاد والمؤسسات الرسميه
[موسيقى]
من جديد تعود الخلافات بين مكونات الاطار
التنسيقيه بسبب حصص كل مكون في الاطار
لشغل الوظائف المهمه صحيفه المدى العراقيه
اشارت الى ان رئيس الوزراء محمد الشيعه
السوداني يتعرض للضغط من قبل الاحتلاف
دوله القانون لاحداثي مزيدا من التغيير في
المناصب نتحدث هنا عن اكثر من 10,000 منصب
تعرف بالدرجات الخاصه
بالوكاله منذ ما يزيد عن 10 سنوات
سوداني طرح تصوره سابقا بشان شغل المناصب
وهو التريث ودراسه كل موقع وظروفه على حده
المدى نقلت عن مصادر مقربه من الاطار
قولها ان الاطراف التي تضغط على رئيس
الحكومه تحاول اجراء ما يشبه التطهير
السياسي في تلك المناصب المصادر اضافت ان
الحديث يدور حول تغيير 900 منصب دفعه
واحده يغلب عليها مناصب في ضاعت الامنيه
وتحديدا في وزارتي الدفاع والداخليه في
هذا الاطار اشارت المصادر الى ان زعيم
دوله القانون نور المالكي يرفض تولي اعضاء
ميليشيا عصائب اهل الحق مناصب المخابرات
او الامن القومي ايضا بحسب لائحه
التغييرات المسربه يتبين وجود ما يشبه
الاستهداف لفريق رئيس الوزراء السابق
مصطفى الكاظمي الذي تم ابعاد المستشارين
الذين عملوا معه قبل التوجه للاسماء
الاخرى في اللائحه
[موسيقى]
الى ملف الفساد الان معهد شتم هاوس
البريطاني اشار الى ان احزاب ومجموعات
مسلحه تسيطر على قطاع الدواء العراقي
تقرير المعهد قال ان الدواء الذي كان من
المفترض ان يكون متوفرا في المستشفيات
الحكوميه يتم بيعه للقطاع الخاص مقابل
ارباح كجزء من منظومه جمعت المليارات من
الدولارات لحساب نوخ بن سياسيه
على حساب ارواح العراق
فقط من الادويه المتوفره في السوق العراقي
صالحه للاستهلاكه وتكون باهضه الثمن بينما
الادويه الاخرى المتوفره تكون مزوره او
منتهيه الصلاحيه ما ادى لوفاه الكثير من
المرضى اعتبر التقرير ان خصص توريد
الادويه للعراق ساهمت بشكل كبير في انتشار
هذا النوع من الفساد
لاعب بصحه العراقيين تقرير المعهد نقل عن
وزير صحه عراقي سابق قوله ان شبكات للتجار
في الادويه تحقق اربع خمس سنوات تتراوح
بين خمسه وسبعه مليار دولار جزء من
الارباح بحسب شتم هاوس يصل للاحزاب
والمجموعات المسلحه عن طريق تلق الرشاوه
لتسهيل عبور الادويه وتفادي دفع اي رسوم
جمركيه هناك وجه اخر للازمه هو التهرب
الجمركي والضربي الذي يضيع على العراق نحو
عشره مليارات دولار اخرى
سنويا تحديدا ننتقل الى مراسلنا في بغداد
ليطلعنا على جانب من ازمه الادويه
[موسيقى]
نقص الادويه في العراق
الحكوميه عاجزه عن توفير قائمه طويله على
راسها ادويه مرضى السرطان الذين نباتوه
وجبرينا للبحث عنها في السوق السوداء
للحصول عليها باسعار باهظه جدا
بايش الادويه من بره غاليه ب 50 وب 40 و
60 و100 واحنا ناس
تحتكروا 80% من سوق العقاقير الطبيه في
العراق والتي يدخل معظمها الى داخل البلاد
بطرق غير قانونيه
هذا الاحتكار ادى الى وفاه العشرات يوميا
في المستشفيات
بسبب ارتفاع اسعار هذه العقاقير ومع الاسف
على حكومه اللي عدم المتابعه للصيدليات
وازيد الناس تعبانه
والمستشفيات عدم توفر الدواء بيها
فالمواطن وين يطري يروح يطري يروح علما
للخاص رغم حملات التفتيش التي نفذتها
وزاره الصحه والاجهزه الامنيه لعدد من
مداخر الادويه والصيدليات التي تحتقر بعض
العقاقير الطبيه الضروريه الا ان ذلك لم
يوفر حلا لهذه المشكله ولم يوفر الدواء
لمحتاجين من بغداد منتظر الرشيد العربيه
كاميرا العربيه استطلعت اراء عينه من
الشارع العراقي وسالت المواطنين عما اذا
عانوا من صعوبه في الدواء سواء لناحيه
توفره او سعره وعادتنا
مكلف غالي يعني لا يتوفر لا مستشفيات
حكوميه ولا باهليه تجد كل المستشفيات
تعاني من نقص في الدواء ولا يوجد اكثر من
الدواء البسيطه المتعارف واللي براسيتول
او الكبليكس نشيل بسيط اللي ممكن تتناوله
بالف دينار لكن هناك ادويه صعبه همم
يعني اسعارها عاليه اي مسائل موجوده عندنا
بداخل البلد صارت طبيعي المساله المساله
التجاره بس احنا اليوم نتامل انه لاشخاص
الموجودين بهذا المكان انه ياخذون هذا
الموضوع بنضع الاحتبار لسبب واحد ان هم
مطلعين عليهم هم عايشين داخل هذا البلد
احنا اليوم نريد مساله الدواء لكل الطبقات
بالنسبه للمستشفيات يعني علاج ما بيها
نهائيا قطعا ما بها سعر الباص ثلاثه الاف
عيني والعلاج تشتريه من السوق انت ماكو
واحد اشترى علاج اليوم بالمستشفى
وانضم الينا من عمان رعد هاشم المحلل
السياسي العراقي اهلا بك سيد رعد معنا
الليله يعني الارقام صادمه فعليا هل يمكن
بانه اييي 30 بالمئه فقط من الادويه في
العراق صالحه للاستهلاك وبالتالي 70% هي
مزوره او غير صالحه يموت من وراء
المواطنين المرضى تحديدا
دقيقا ومهما وهمم ينم عن الاطلاع مفصل عن
دقائق الامور لك ان تتحدث ايضا عن اكبر من
هذه النسبه اذا ما عرفنا انه هناك ادويه
بعينها غير مسجله في وزاره الصحه وبالتالي
هناك صرار من قبل الفصائل معينه مسلحين
احزاب على عدم تسجيلها ربما يتساءل لماذا
لم تسجل لانه حينما تدخل بين منافذ تؤشر
غير مسجله بواقع هي طبعا يقال انه الادويه
المسجله فقط في وزاره الصحه 4,000 نوع من
الادويه
ومعلوم للجميع انه اكثر من 100,000 واكثر
طبعا من هذا الرقم من الادويه الاخرى
المعتمده غير مسجله حينما تاتي الى
المنافذ الحدوديه التي غالبا ما يسيطر
عليها كتائب حزب الله والكتائب والفصائل
والاحزاب الاخ التي لديها همم اصابات
مسلحه تدخل طبعا يعني اعتماد انه غير
مسجله مما يعني يضطرون الى اعادتها او
يصار الى اعادتها
ويعني تدخل مره اخرى بطريقه اخرى عبر
الرشاوه هذه القضيه يقف امامها همم حيتان
كبيره تدخل في السوق الدوائي تدخل في همم
يعني غسيل الاموال عبر تشغيل اموال في هذه
المداخل في هذه الصيدليات
وحقيقه القرار الدواء كله تتحكم فيه
احزان الحكومه التي تعذر ولادتها وتعذر
همم اعطاء الثقه لها الان اعلنت اعطيت
الثقه فعليا همم كان هناك همم خلاف على
عده اسماء عينت هذه الاسماء ان كان وزا او
مناصب عليا يعني اذا كانت هذه الحكومه
تريد القضاء على الفساد لماذا لا تزال تصر
هذه الاحزاب وهذه الحكومه على تعيين اسماء
مرتبطه بخلفيات سياسيه وليس يعني بتطهيريه
لهذا الفساد لانه كمان نشاهد النتائج على
الارض الناس تموت
انه هم الذين جاءوا به وانا تقريركم طبعا
سمعتوا واضيفه ايضا اضاءه للمالكي ايضا
تلح كثيرا على همم على السوداني ايضا في
توظيف او تعيين
الكوادر والقادر اللي يعني مواليد لها ولي
ايران
السوق الاجهزه الامنيه والمناصب بالدراجات
الخاصه ما نحن فيه يعني انا اقول انه هي
اللي جابته تشعر انه هي التي تريد ان تفرض
رغم انه هناك اراده لدى الرجل انه على
تعيين بعض المستقلين او حتى بعض الكفاءات
ولكن يعني امام هذا
الحزبي
المملشن بعضه يعني الفصائل الموالي تشير
الى انه هي ما انا تريد هيمنه مطلقه لا
تريد للمستقلين ان يكون لهم حضور للكفاءات
ان يكون لهم تواجد وبذلك انا في تقديري
اذا ما استمر الحال على هذا الوضع سيكون
موضوع القضاء على الفساد قضيه سامي يجي
ربما وشكليه انت تعلمين انه معظم الادويه
المنافذ الدوائيه التي تاتي من ايران
مزوره بنسبه كبيره جدا جدا همم هي همم
يعني ايضا يعني تتبع اللي همم شركات
وماركات لفايزر شركه فايزر وايضا استرزان
اللي الماركات الامريكيه تاتي بتغيير
علامات معينه هنا وهناك او حرف هنا وهناك
وتصدق العالم فيها هذه شوف التزييف
الايراني حتى في الدواء لكي تقتل العراقين
وبالتالي ايضا هناك ادويه تباع في السوق
العراقي رخيصه كانت في السابق
هذه تستعمل للكحه يستخدموها الايرانيين
باضافه مواد معينه لكي تعاد الى العراق
بهيئه مخدرات يعني كثير من الاعمال
الاحتياليه كثير من الحيتان الفساد يعملون
همم بحقيقه بشكل مكشوف وواضح لكن ليست
هناك اراده سياسيه حقيقي
شكرا جزيلا لك المحل الاساسي العراقي
[موسيقى]
في ملف العمليات العسكريه التركيه في
سوريا والعراق اكدت الحكومه التركيه الا
تراجع عن الحزام الامني على الحدود مع
سوريا
على حدودها مع سوريا رغم التحضيرات
الامريكيه وامكانيه
في الشمال السوري
حزام يمتد على طول الحدود مع سوريا بعمق
30 كم وتهدف انقره من خلاله لتامين حدودها
من الهجمات الارهابيه وايضا طرد المجموعات
الكرديه من الشمال السوري
ورغم تفاهمها لما خوف الاتراك الا انا
واشنطن حذرت انقره من مغبه تعطيل عمليه
القوات الامريكيه والكرديه ضد تنظيم داعش
في سوريا
ليست هناك خصومه دائمه في السياسه هذا ما
اكده الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان عندما
تطرق الى علاقه بلاده مع سوريا في الوقت
الذي تسع موسكو لترتيب لقاء بين اردوغان
والرئيس السوري بشار الاسد الذي رفض
اللقاء ما لم تنسحب القوات التركيه بشكل
كامل من الاراضي السوريه
على الارض ازدادت التحركات العسكريه حيث
سيره القوات الامريكيه دوريات المشتركه مع
قوات الاسد واشرت قوات التحالف تدريبات في
قاعدتها بحقل كونغو كما وصلت تعزيزات
كرديه من 600 جندي باليات ومدافع ودبابات
الى ريف حلب
مؤشرات على ان الوضع متجه نحو مواجهه
عسكريه غريبه
في المونديال فرنسا تنضم ل 8 الكبار على
حسابي بولندا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الدول الفقيره تدفع
فاتوره باهظه لارتفاع اسعار الفائده
والتضخم على شكل ازمات متفاقمه ابرزها
طوفان اقتصادي يغرقها فيديو مقال تحليلي
في صحيفه نيويورك تايمز اشار الى ملامح
الازمه التي ستعصف باقتصاد الدول الناميه
التي ستعاني الامرين اقتصاد مترهل في
اساسه يضاف اليه عبء سداد الديون والتخلف
عن دفعها ووفق بيانات نوك تايمز تدين هذه
الدول الفقيره بما يصل الى 200 مليار
دولار للدول الغنيه وبنوك التنميه
المتعدده الاطراف والزائنين من القطاع
الخاص
تداعيات ازمات عالميه تنكب متواليا على
رؤوس تلك الدول الفقيره بدات بجائزه
كورونا واغلاقاتها صارمه وحرب روسيا في
اوكرانيا منذ تسعه اشهر وبحسب الصحيفه
تحدث ازمه ماليه عالميه لكن التخلف عن
السداد يمكن ان يجعل من الصعب على دول مثل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التصدير
البضائع الى دول المثقله بالديون مما يؤدي
الى زياده التابات والاقتصاد العالمي
وربما يؤدي الى انتشار الجوع والاضطرابات
الاجتماعيه في بعض تلك الدول حيث توقع
البنك الدولي هذا العام ان حوالي 12 دوله
قد تواجهوا تخلفا عن السداد في العام
المقبل وقدر صندوق صندوق النادي الدولي ان
60% من البلدان الناميه منخفضه الدخل كانت
في ضائقه ديون او معرضه لخطر كبير من
ضمنهم سيرلانكا التي اقتربت من التخلف عن
السداد هذا العامه والتره مصرفها المركزي
الى ترتيب اتفاقيه مقايده لدفع ثمن النفط
الايراني باوراق الشاي حتى الاسواق
الناشئه في تشاد وساميه وغانا تكافا حليب
تطوير خطه لتسريع لتخفيف الديون التي مهدد
اقتصاده هذه الدول بالوايلات وكان محللون
انتقدوا خلال الاجتماعات السنويه لصندوق
النقد الدولي والبنك الدولي في واشنطن
خلال اكتوبر الماضي بطء وتيره اعاده هيكله
الديون ودعوا الى اتخاذ اجراءات منسقه بين
الزائنين والمقترضين لايجاد حلول قبل فوات
الاوان وما تزال الصين التي اصبحت واحده
من اكبر الدائنين في العالم تشكل وعقبه
امام جهود الاغاثه وقد اتهمها خبراء
التنميه بوضع مصائد ديون البلدان الناميه
من خلال برنامج اقراض يزيد عن 500 مليار
وصفه محللون بالخطه المفترسه
[موسيقى]
تصيح اليوم مشاهدينا اصبح اكثر ذرايه
بتحديات التي يواجهها الجيش الروسي في
اوكرانيا لكن من غير الواضح ما اذا كان
يترك بالكامل حجم الصعوبه التصريح حوالي
مديره الاستخبارات الوطنيه
[موسيقى]
المشكله الاكبر الان ان التقدم على الارض
لم يعد مرتبطا بسلاح مقابل السلاح وانما
ببردج شتاء يضغط على الجميع
اخذه في التزايد في صفوف الغربي
ماسوره اليوم فهي من لبنان الم يا ابي انك
سرطان بلا عمل فالسياسه في بلادنا لم تعد
تهتم بك السياسه اصلا لم تعد تعمل اعدك
انني ساراجع دروسي ساراجعها بكل اجتهاد
حتى لو ضاق بنا المكان والحل ساراجعها كي
اكبر واصبح طبيبه او مهندسه واساعدك على
تحمل عناء المعيشه لا وقت للعب الان ففي
بلادنا لا شيء في مكانه ولا شيئا في وقته
ملفاتنا لليوم المزيد على العربيه دوت نت